[Musique]
de la Champagne nous connaissons d'abord
le vin et ses bulles qui nous enivrent
le champagne a offert à ce qui n'était
au Moyen-Âge qu'un petit vignoble
ordinaire de l'Est de la France un
rayonnement inégalé dans le monde
traverser ce territoire cette admirer un
décor tout en nuances de verre une vaste
mosaïque de parcelle morcelée des
alignements de vignes qui se croisent et
se recroisent à l'infini et douceur
émergent ici et là quelques clochers
ces coteaux produisent un vin synonyme
dans le monde entier de luxe et de fait
pourtant quand on boit une gorgée c'est
la mémoire des moines et du clergé qui
refait surface
la Champagne est une fenêtre ouverte sur
le passé moyen-âgeeux ou le lien entre
Église et vigne ses forgée
dans la faible lueur des abbayes les
religieux ont créé la recette qui a
transformé la région de Champagne à
jamais
[Musique]
métropole incontournable de l'époque
gallo-romaine où l’élite chrétienne
jouira d'emblée du Nora exceptionnelle
la cathédrale édifice somptueux dont la
construction débutée en 1211 s'est étalé
sur plusieurs siècles en est le symbole
le plus fort
son architecture très ajourée et sa
collection de statues qui ornent
l'extérieur de l'église en font un joyau
de l'art gothique
et partout les symboles du vin nous
rappelle l'origine du champagne
la vigne est très présente dans le décor
sculpté de la cathédrale et il n'y a pas
de meilleur endroit pour parler des
rapports entre l'église et la
viticulture qu'une cathédrale puisque
c'est l'église de l'évêque et ce sont
les évêques qui ont joué vraiment un
rôle clé dans la transmission des bonnes
méthodes de culture et surtout de
consommation de consommation du vin
au 5e siècle l'évêque de Reims s'appelle
Saint-Rémy et la légende de l'associe
largement à la promotion du vin un vin
rouge ordinaire avant tout symbole du
sang du Christ et dont l'Église a besoin
pour célébrer la messe
Saint-Rémy est le premier viticulteur
connu en Champagne parce que c'est dans
son testament rédigé vers 530 que l'on
trouve la trace écrite des premières
vignes dont une dit-il qu'il a planté de
ses mains dont il a pris un soin
particulier alors c'est exprimé sur
cette cathédrale par un des miracles
attribué à saint-rémie que l'on voit
là-haut bénir un tonneau quasiment vide
qui se remplit miraculeusement alors
c'est tout à fait révélateur du rôle de
l'évêque qui doit célébrer l'Eucharistie
et distribuer le vin consacré à la
population chrétienne
[Musique]
pratiquement tous les chapitaux de la
cathédrale présente un décor de
feuillage rares sont les chapiteaux
historiques et c'est d'autant plus
intéressant de voir celui-ci qui
représente une scène de vendanges ou
plus exactement un garde qui appréhende
un maraudeur en lui mettant la main sur
l'épaule alors ça nous rappelle que les
chanoines étaient les propriétaires de
vignobles qu'il veillaient évidemment la
conservation de leur récolte c'est un
peu un avertissement il est sacrilège de
s'en prendre au vignoble des chanoines
car tous les biens de l'église
Notre-Dame appartiennent à Notre-Dame
voler le clergé c'est voler les seins
Saint-Rémy viticulteur renommée et
surtout rester dans l'histoire comme
l'évêque ayant converti puis baptisé
Clovis en 496 au cœur même de la
cathédrale
Reims devant ainsi l'épicentre de la
couronne car tous les rois de France Var
se faire sacrer en son sein
[Musique]
sera décisif sur l'économie du vin
depuis la cathédrale on voit les reliefs
qui entourent la ville de Reims c'est la
côte d'Île-de-France dont le sommet
boisé et dont les pentes portent le
vignoble depuis l'époque gallo-romaine
le Haut Moyen-Âge la vigne est là aux
portes de la cité et le vin rentrait
dans la ville
le vin de Champagne était associé au
sacre depuis le Moyen-Âge le vin
effervescent depuis le 18e siècle à
partir du sacre de Louis XV et vin de la
fête vin de la célébration il est
évident que cette image a été très tôt
mise en avant par les Champenois pour
faire de ce breuvage qu'on appelle aussi
le vin des rois et le roi des vins un
produit d'excellence de bon goût et qui
est le reflet du savoir-vivre à la
française
[Musique]
on dit que la conversion de Clovis a
fait de la France la fille aînée de
l'Église catholique
les communautés monastiques se
développent largement à cette époque et
notamment en Champagne sous l'influence
croissante de l'évêché de Reims
très vite il deviendront les artisans de
la vigne
à quelques kilomètres de la cathédrale
s'étend la Montagne de Reims un paysage
de coteaux coincé entre des plateaux
boisés et la Marne au cœur de ce cirque
se niche un village dont on dit qu'il
est le berceau du champagne ovilée
l'abbaye Saint-Pierre de Villé
occupé par des frères jusqu'à la
Révolution fut l'une des plus ardentes
bâtisseuses du savoir-faire champenois
transformant ce qui n'était alors qu'un
vin rouge tranquille en un breuvage que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui
[Musique]
voici la
la source de ce qui a conduit la
Champagne et le champagne à avoir sa
renommée dans le monde
on est ici devant la pierre tombale de
Dompierre Pérignon qui pendant 47 ans a
administrer le domaine à gérer les
vignes et a permis aux vins de Champagne
d'acquérir toutes ces lettres de
noblesse ce qu'il a fait c'est inscrire
le vin de Champagne dans une révolution
du goût et on sort d'une logique où le
vin n'est plus bu pour la soif mais
surtout pour le plaisir qu'il procure et
donc la qualité qui qui en est le
résultat
[Musique]
Touré du nom entretenu mais les rares
écrits que l'on possède s'accordent
c'est-à-dire qu'il a fait du vin
d'auvillé un produit d'exception que
certains auraient même qualifié de
meilleurs vins du monde
l'activité viticole était bien la clé de
voûte de l'abbaye
si aujourd'hui ce Lunel du cloître à
résisté aux effets du temps il faut
imaginer qu'au 17ème siècle une grande
partie des lieux était dédiée à la
production du vin en fait le vin est
essentiel dans la vie dans monastère
d'abord et en premier lieu pour la
liturgie il faut du vin pour la messe
ensuite on utilisait du vin pour faire
des médicaments puisque c'est une base
d'alcool on pouvait faire des décoctions
c'est aussi pour un monastère qui vit en
de façon très autarcique le seul moyen
d'avoir de l'argent qui va lui permettre
de de d'engager des travaux notamment
pour restaurer les bâtiments et leur
donner une une dignité conforme à l'oral
de l'abbaye
les moines sont à l'époque les salles à
posséder les moyens et surtout le temps
pour parfaire les techniques de
vinification
cette stabilité a permis de presser un
vin presque transparent faisant rayonner
le vignoble partout en Europe
on a ici un des plus beaux paysages de
champagne on peut imaginer dans Pérignon
ici venir contempler son domaine et donc
la géographie est restée la même toutes
les vignes qu'on peut voir autour de
l'abbaye correspondent au terrain qui
était planté de vigne à l'époque de
Dampierre Pérignon et d'ailleurs les
parcelles sont toujours
connues sous le même vocable qu'on
connaissait à l'époque de l'abbaye donc
sur le la partie à droite on a la
parcelle des hautes prières qui étaient
clairement une des une des parcelles de
l'abbaye
encore très morcelé aujourd'hui le
paysage singulier des coteaux de
champagne est à l'origine même de sa
légende
abreuvez de raisins cultivés sur des
parcelles très différentes on dit que
Don pierre Perignon a fait de
l'assemblage une force une alchimie qui
fait aujourd'hui toutes les spécificités
de ces vins faut bien comprendre que
cette obsession de la qualité elle est
aussi inhérente à l'esprit bénédictin la
devise des moines bénédictins c'est aura
être laborah c'est je prie et je
travaille pour eux chaque geste chaque
moment de leur vie doit être une louange
à Dieu donc cet esprit de la qualité
qu'on retrouve dans les habitudes de Dom
Pérignon il les tient parce qu'il est
moins de bénédictins et que on l'a formé
à à
faire le mieux possible tout ce qu'il
fait à tout moment de sa vie
les moines ont laissé à la Champagne un
savoir-faire unique dans les
viticulteurs modernes sont les héritiers
[Musique]
plus d'une centaine de kilomètres au sud
dans l'Aube s'étendent un pays qu'on
appelle la Côte des Bars l'autre pays du
champagne
c'est l'abbaye de Clairvaux à son apogée
ses 800 membres exploités l'essentiel
des vignes de cette région
[Musique]
dans le village de Collombey le sec les
moines ne sont plus présents mais leur
grange leur ont survécu et le vin n'a
pas quitté les lieux
[Musique]
là donc c'est le CIO moine et c'était
une dépendance de l'abbaye chaos donc à
20 km d'ici à peu près et donc les mois
n'ont vécu ici du 12e jusque 18e siècle
les gestes immuables initiés par les
religieux en ces lieux sont toujours
reproduits aujourd'hui inlassablement
il faut tourner d'un quart de tour
chaque bouteille pour faire tomber les
lits vers le boulot et produire ainsi ce
vin pétillant si singulier les mois nous
ont transmis leur savoir-faire au niveau
viticole c'est eux qui ont déjà commencé
à implanter et à les cultiver et à les
vinifier et puis après il faisait tout
aussi à la main comme on fait ici on
reste très traditionnel on veut pas
dénaturer le lieu donc on conserve
vraiment les méthodes ancestrales on va
dire
ça fait quand même quelque chose on sent
l'histoire ici de tout ce qui s'est
passé tout le monde qui a eu qui sont
venus vivre ici en fait au fil des
années donc de redonner la nature
première à cette cave c'était
impressionnant
donc ici cette parcelle elle s'appelle
pis 20 ça donne beaucoup de raisins et
donc c'était une parcelle qui était déjà
là lors des moines et donc c'est du
Pinot Noir là comme comme à l'époque en
fait
on travaille en fait la terre des moines
eux où ils avaient déjà planté et
finalement on a même avec toute la
technologie tout d'aujourd'hui on garde
cette même terre en fait ici on laboure
le même sol c'est bien que ça perdure
d'année en année de siècles et puis de
famille en famille
[Musique]
la Champagne est un terroir de légende
un paysage façonné par plus d'un millier
d'années d'histoires monacales et si
désormais produire le roi des vins n'est
plus vraiment une manière de rendre
grâce à Dieu les vignerons semblent plus
que jamais prendre soin de la vigne avec
la même dévotion
[Musique]
900 ans que les champs et les prières
des moines cisterciens résonnent entre
les murs de l'abbaye de Sénanque
[Musique]
isolé au fond d'une vallée du Luberon
elle est l'une des nombreuses merveilles
architecturales de la région
ce territoire au relief accidenté ne
serait pas ce paysage parsemé de village
au perché si dès le 4e siècle les
chrétiens déjà très implantés dans la
région ne s'y était enracinée
nous sommes dans une vallée qui est
d'ailleurs très étroite et qui donc
favorise le recueillement
si nous étions au sommet d'une montagne
on aurait tendance bien sûr à regarder à
l'extérieur et nous éparpiller
[Musique]
c'est depuis les villes romaines que
cette conquête des campagnes va
s'organiser
dès le quatrième siècle donc les
premiers chrétiens investissent les
nombreuses cités romaines provençales
dans le Luberon apte placez sous
l'autorité de l'évêque devient cité
épiscopal
[Musique]
l'homme étant son influence au fil des
siècles jusqu'à faire de la cathédrale
Sainte-Anne le cœur de la ville locale
[Musique]
ériger à partir du 11ème siècle ce
monument d'arromond égotique est
construit sur ce que l'église possède de
plus précieux
[Musique]
là on est dans les cryptes au-dessus on
a l'hôtel majeur et lui-même est
surmonté par le clocher qui émerge des
toitures encore aujourd'hui donc il faut
imaginer que la période médiévale ça
s'imposait au regard donc on est au
coeur de la cathédrale au cœur de sa
monumentalité au cœur de sa sacralité
puisque c'est ici qui était déposé les
reliques des principaux évêques de la
cité
l'évêque baptise Marie célèbre les
messes et rythme ainsi la vie
quotidienne des fidèles
dès le 5ème sixième siècle l'évêque est
une autorité spirituelle une notoriété
religieuse mais ça va au-delà
c'est-à-dire que l'évêque va assumer
toute une série de responsabilités liées
à la ville l'évêque construit est un
bâtisseur et donc l'évêque crée un
paysage monumental nouveau qui donne la
ville médiévale qui succède sont
totalement effacées la vie de
l'antiquité mais va donner un paysage
monumental chrétien
la présence d'un évêque c'est pas
simplement la ville mais c'est aussi son
territoire puisque le va se mettre en
place le diocèse lui-même héritier du
territoire de la cité antique et donc ça
donne un espace de rayonnement de la
ville très marquée
dans le diocèse d'Apt à moins de 10 km
la tour du prieuré de Saint-Symphorien
il se trouve sur la terre d'une
puissante famille locale les Lacoste
Castellane qui ont fait don de ce petit
bout du Luberon à une communauté de
moines au XIIe siècle
en échange de leur prière les religieux
s'y installent et construisent un lieu
de culte qui va devenir central pour la
vie de cette campagne
[Musique]
cette tour qui était un peu un miracle
aujourd'hui l'impressionne vous imaginez
il y a 1000 ans cette tour bâtie au
milieu du Luberon est un signal fort de
l'existence de Dieu les moines de
Saint-Symphorien vont peu à peu fédérer
les habitants déjà présents dans la
région il y a eu des champs un peu
partout et donc des petits hameaux des
petits villages ça c'était le centre
religieux de cette vallée qui va de
Lourmarin à Apt et les pèlerins les
voyageurs s'arrêtaient le soir dormez là
et c'était pas seulement nombre sacré
c'est aussi un lieu de rencontre un lieu
de vie
en contrebas de l'édifice des vestiges
indiquent d'ailleurs la présence d'un
village ecclésial
toute une vie s'est organisée ici autour
des religieux
cette bâtisse considérée comme l'un des
plus beaux édifices d'art au monde du
Luberon est aujourd'hui une habitation
privée ouverte un jour par an aux
visiteurs
le petit groupe de moines y vivra
pendant plus de 300 ans
la chapelle dans laquelle nous sommes
maintenant date de
950-960 donc il était une petite
chapelle rurale l'aspect religieux était
ici c'était consacré aux séquences
derrière il voulait partir domestiques
il y a eu un agrandissement au milieu du
11e siècle quand les mois de l'ont reçu
en donation ils ont construit pour le
public de la vallée c'est de l'appel qui
est magnifique qui est très rare parce
qu'elle est très longue très haute et
très étroite
ce bâtiment je le connaissais puisque
quand j'étais tout petit je vais venir
avec mes parents faire des des pêches
les écrevisses autrui c'est un petit
rivière en dessous et pour moi c'était
un monument un peu fantasmatique c'était
un théorie vous êtes magnifique il y a
eu des énormes chaînes au milieu là où
nous sommes il y a des chaînes comme ça
Daniel Vial rachète ce prieuré à
l'abandon dans les années 80 durant
trois ans archéologue et artisan vont le
reconstruire pierre par pierre nous
avions non seulement tous les matériaux
qui étaient autour du prieuré on n'a pas
amené une seule pierre de l'extérieur et
nous avions également toutes les signaux
architecturaux qui montraient qu'elle
était le volume des pièces la hauteur de
chaque mur etc donc en fait il y avait
aucun risque d'erreur donc nous avons
restitué les priorités qu'il était au
GMC
à partir du 9e siècle les monastères
fleurissent dans la région
face à certains excès du clergé les
fidèles se tournent vers des ordres de
plus en plus rigoureux comme les frères
Karm chassaient du Mont Carmel en
Palestine après la deuxième croisade et
accueilli par les habitants de Ménerbes
au 13e siècle
c'est là qu'il construisent l'abbaye
Saint-Hilaire
les pauvre frère quand ils sont arrivés
on leur a donné la pente qui restait
c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre mais
en échange ils sont au soleil ils ont le
soleil plus longtemps que les maisons
qui sont en face ils ont mis en pratique
ce qu'il connaissait déjà au
Moyen-Orient parce que le mont Carmel
est une montagne qui ressemble au
Luberon c'est ça qui est tout à fait
surprenant 30 km de long 500 mètres de
haut même végétation et même sommet plat
et puis dans la vallée du blé de la
vigne etc donc là-bas il y avait des
murs de pierre sèches donc ici ils ont
continué et on se retrouve avec ces
fameux murs qui sont obligatoires pour
retenir la terre
derrière cette façade provençale un
couvent de campagne fortifiée où les
frères Karm Elise résidence pendant près
de cinq siècles
c'est dans ce cloître et bien c'est un
lieu
réservé aux morts vous avez à peu près
des fouilles ont été faites en 1996
trois niveaux de squelette encore
directement dans la terre donc c'est
très important quand on entrait à
Saint-Hilaire et bien on en sortait
jamais
les Carmes revendique une pauvreté
absolue pour survivre dans ce lieu
reculé du Luberon les moines de cet
ordre mondial vont devoir aller à la
rencontre des laïcs ils prêchent la
bonne parole et donne les sacrements et
avec les seigneurs de la région les
premiers mécènes de l'église les moines
nous des alliances étroites à
Saint-Hilaire les inscriptions
funéraires gravées sur le mur du cloître
souligne l'importance d'une certaine
dame Béatrice bienfaitrice du couvent la
tradition au 13ème siècle c'est que les
personnes les plus aisées sont les
aristocrates et c'est une époque où on
craint la mort où on a besoin d'avoir de
l'appui pour aller au ciel et finalement
rien de mieux d'avoir les religieux
comme garant de cette future vie au ciel
[Musique]
si vous me dites il y a des esprits je
dirais oui s'il y a des bruits bizarres
je dirais oui le vent les rafales tout
ça ça fait du bruit partout dans tous
les sens c'est comme ça il y a cette
ambiance insolite
[Musique]
alors que les frères Karm participent à
l'évangélisation des campagnes à
quelques kilomètres au nord de Ménerbes
la communauté cistercienne va devenir
une vraie puissance économique cet ordre
qui prône un rigorisme absolu s'impose
dans toute l'Europe au 12e siècle
lorsque les cisterciens s'établissent
dans ce désert des mondes du Vaucluse
dans l'abbaye Notre-Dame de Sénanque
leur volonté est bien de se couper du
monde afin de suivre les préceptes de
leur père fondateurs Saint-Benoît
en parle lui-même on sera davantage
moine si on participe au récolte on est
en communion avec la nature et surtout
pour nous surtout le matin où nous
sommes encore tout rempli le silence et
de la présence de Dieu nous sommes en
communion vraiment avec le créateur
cette communion avec la nature fait des
cisterciens de sénanques d'excellents
cultivateurs ils élèvent également du
bétail alors apogée grâce aux dons et à
leur travail la quarantaine de moines
devient un important propriétaire
terrien de la région alors même jusqu'à
acquérir un hôpital dans la ville
d'Arles au début du 14e siècle il y a eu
un grand rayonnement on a jusqu'à 7
granges avec des frères qui allaient
jusqu'à 30 km d'ici et donc on était une
période assez phase avec un assez grand
nombre certainement de moines avec des
abbés qui étaient assez distingués et
qui avait même des relations avec le
Pape surtout au 14e siècle mais saviez
il y avait les papas Avignon
aujourd'hui encore les 7 moines mènent
entre ces murs une vie millimétrée elle
est dictée par l'architecture
cistercienne plus ou moins identique
dans les 300 édifices que possède
l'ordre un peu partout en Europe
autour du cloître la vie religieuse
s'organise
cette prière par jour des temps de
lecture de méditation et bien sûr de
repas
vivre justement dans cette architecture
du 12e siècle et remarquable ce nank
c'est certainement stimulant pour nous
on aime ce lieu splendide le fait d'être
aussi en communion avec ceux qui ont pu
vivre ici puisque pour nous ils ne sont
pas morts ils vivent une autre vie et
donc il y a certainement bon une sorte
de communion spirituelle avec nos
anciens qui est réel
tous ces édifices religieux qui
affichent la puissance de l'église
seront récupérés par l'État lors de la
Révolution française
il reste encore aujourd'hui les témoins
de l'essor du christianisme dans le
Luberon
[Musique]